[Music]
joining me today is Oliver Tweety from
sky director of data engineering and
today we're going to be talking through
real-time streaming analytics with data
flow common use cases and patterns but
before we dive straight into patterns
it's important to understand streaming
and why it matters and a couple of
things that the Apache beam SDK and
dataflow do to solve some of the common
problems that you may run into so we can
have data that we're processing and that
data can be big for instance we can be
processing from gigabytes to terabytes
it could be really really big so we may
have huge amounts of data that we want
to process every day in multiple days
that we want to process and that data
can also be infinitely big so we may
have streaming data that's constantly
coming it never stops
and this gives a problem with processing
especially with unknown delays so one of
the more difficult things with unbounded
data is unknown delays so assuming that
every record has an event timestamp
hopefully we would see the records show
up shortly after the event that occurred
so we're going to look over here the red
record here happened at 8 a.m. and it
showed up in the system shortly after
the yellow record happened at 8 a.m. and
showed up in the system slightly delayed
but then we have this green act record
over here that has an event timestamp of
8 a.m. but showed up at 2:30 which is
about a 6 hour delay and there's several
reasons why these delays may happen the
most common case is actually mobile
devices so with mobile devices you can
imagine that you get on a plane you turn
your plane your phone onto you airplane
mode you play a game on your mobile
device the entire plane ride when you
get off you turn your airplane mode off
and all those events shoot up to the
cloud and so you get all these events
into your data pipeline all at once
because we had no connectivity during
that period now if we were doing element
wise transforms such as just
filtering out for the yellow records
here that's relatively simple we don't
care about processing time or event time
it's easy because it's a continuous
transform but when we get to grouping
data via processing time windows so
let's say we want to do an aggregation
we want to count the number of events
that happened per user for batch it's
easy because it's bounded we just read
the input stream and then as soon as
there's no more data we stop processing
and we calculate the result and omit it
for streaming we can't do that you never
run out of data so there's no way of
saying like this is the time where I
output the count that I've seen so what
we most commonly what people want to do
is group data into processing time
windows or windows rather and divide
data up into small chunks so that they
can compute aggregations over that chunk
of time and then output results so
initial approach is to use processing
time windows essentially when a job sees
a record it looks at the wall clock it
does that for a minute and then outputs
a record but what we really may want to
do is actually group that by event time
so instead of viewing something as time
on the wall clock viewing data as a
stream and group by our event timestamps
within our data and output them as we
see them this allows us to perform
calculations over the event time
interval which the events have occurred
so essentially what we do is we take the
input which is all the events occurring
at processing time we regroup them and
shuffle them to group them into event
time and calculate meaningful analytics
over our data so I mentioned Windows
what is a window a window is just a
function to divide data into chunks
within the Apache beam SDK and dataflow
we provide several different window
types to slice and dice your data in
different ways so for inches here's some
some of the more common ones fixed
windows in sliding windows so a fixed
window you can think of it as
scene data from like 1 2 2 2 2 3 so on
and so forth
and so you're pretty much dividing up
your data into time chunks and then
grouping it and providing some
aggregation on that data sliding window
so you can think of those as overlapping
fixed windows so an event that happened
may actually end up in multiple
different windows so say that I had a
sliding window that was an hour and it
slides every minute I essentially have
windows that end up being 12:01 2 101
102 or 1202 to 102 so on and so forth so
I could have a lot of overlapping
windows and this is useful when you're
doing things like analysis on maybe the
input rate of the data or calculating
how many events that I've seen in the
past minute or 10 minutes for a
particular event type in beam we also
support data dependent windows so what
if I wanted to group by something that
was in my my event itself so I want to
create windows for users for instance
this is what we would call sessions so
every key here ends up in a different
window sessions are defined by whenever
there's a burst of activity I want to
group that into a window for processing
and calculate statistics over that and
then when there's no data for a period
of time such as a gap I'm going to close
that window and fire it off this is a
common thing you may want to do in
analytics and it supported
out-of-the-box and data flow and Apache
beam so I've talked a little bit about
the windowing semantics and how we would
divide our data up and maybe do
computations over it within a real-time
analytics pipeline but when does the
answer come out this is problematic
because you have to know when to emit
the result for the data that you're
seeing for that window by default what
we have is something called a watermark
the watermark tries to know when we were
done with data for a window
so if the watermark says 12 o'clock it
means to the best of our knowledge
there's no more data left before 12
o'clock and we can calculate the result
in a minute downstream for external
sources it has to be somewhat heuristic
so for instance for pub/sub we can
actually do a read ahead of the pub/sub
buffer to essentially look at is there
any more messages left before a certain
period of time and then know that we can
effectively emit the results now going
back to the mobile phone on a plain
example you could have someone who has
data from 11 o'clock on their phone they
don't have any internet connectivity and
obviously we can't know about that so
that actually becomes late data so if we
look at the heuristic watermark here
essentially you can see that while it
does pretty well it doesn't catch the 9
that happens a lot later than we
expected for the perfect watermark it is
perfect it knows about everything
including events that may happen in the
future so what happens when you have
late data in the beam SDK we have a way
of saying that I want to process late
data you can add triggering to your
windows to indicates you want to process
that late data and there's several
different ways of processing it so for
instance using accumulating processing
means that if I have late say to show up
I want to add that late data to my
previous aggregation so for instance if
I was counting elements and I had a
count to 50 before and that late data
shows up I give I fire off that late
data and I get back a result of 52
instead of the original 50 when it went
to a late elements show up I can also
say I want to discard late data or
discard fired panes rather so
essentially if I wanted to do this
counting compute the sum I could have 50
elements that show up on time I could
have two elements that show up late and
as opposed to recalculating the results
and firing off 52 I may say forget about
the 50 that I had previously calculated
I only want to get the count of two and
discard those previous
fired pains so in this other animation
you can actually see some of our
speculative in late firings so in this
case the heuristic watermark is actually
firing speculatively for for records
that show up before the watermark and
then also catching those late records
for a given period of time so we're
actually able to capture a lot of that
data that does not show up when we would
expect it so that was a little bit about
streaming and sort of the common
challenges in how data flow and the
Apache beam SDK helps address some of
those challenges for the subsequent
section we're actually going to talk
about building a pipeline using some
common patterns so from simple
element-wise transforms to you know
grouping aggregations and that type
stuff for this we're actually going to
use the scenario that I've been alluding
to previously of capturing events and
analyzing them for a mobile game so
let's imagine we have a mobile game and
we want to build a real-time analytics
pipelines who analyze those game events
that may be happening and so and we want
our game to be popular too so we want to
be able to handle these events at scale
and be able to do interesting things
like compute aggregations over how many
events that we're seeing per user or
analyze the user behavior within the
game app we'll start out with exactly
once processing so starting to build
this pipeline from the most simple case
we may have our gaming devices
publishing up data into pub/sub then
data flow processing that data and then
bigquery finally landing that data into
our data warehouse we using pub/sub
because it's a reliable globally
available message delivery service and
we expect our game to be popular
worldwide so why not now if we're
analyzing user behavior duplicates which
may answer our system may throw off our
analytics right so if I'm calculating
counts if I'm doing averages if I allow
duplicates into my system I'm going to
throw off the analytics that I'm doing
and thus make them substantially less
valuable and this is also critical in
other industries such as you know retail
or finance so imagine I have a POS
system which is generating transaction
events I obviously wouldn't want to
double count those transactions and same
thing with trades or Holdings in this
example zooming in on to the to cloud
pub/sub you may think that it may cause
a problem because it has at least once
delivery semantics so inherently by
using pub/sub we may receive duplicates
within our system here the colors
indicate unique keys for the records so
we have red yellow green kameena
and we may have duplicate records that
come out however when combining pub/sub
with dataflow we're actually able to
achieve this exactly once semantics
within our pipeline and it's with
relatively little effort so we're gonna
zoom in a little bit on the records
coming into our pipeline they may look
like this we have attributes in a
payload but that comprises the message
that's going into pub some attributes
are key value pairs you can think of it
as a header on the message it allows you
to sort of inspect the message and maybe
route it in different ways to perform
other operations without having to
actually deserialize the payload and the
payload contains the serialized payload
of our message in this case we're
publishing JSON events up into our pub
subtopic and you'll see that we have a
unique identifier within the message
payload in event ID so the first step to
actually processing this in exactly once
fashion is that will promote this event
ID into our attributes and this allows
us to instruct data flow to react to it
within our pipeline and start
deduplicating these messages so we take
a look at our example pipeline here for
our game events it may look like the
following so essentially we have a pub
sub bio transform it's reading some data
from a subscription and that is passing
down data downstream to our transforms
so the first step was to add in that
event ID into our action
buttes now we need to instruct dataflow
to react to that event ID and that's
relatively simple here as opposed to
just having a very vanilla transform
with just specifying the subscription we
add in this dot with ID attribute and
this allows data flow to know I'm gonna
look at this event ID and D duplicate on
that as messages come in to their the
pipeline now this will D duplicate
messages that are being caused by
pub/sub so any messages that are
duplicated as part of pub subs at least
once delivery semantics will be
duplicated automatically within the
pipeline there's also other areas in
which we could receive duplicate
messages such as a publisher may be
publishing a message twice this will
also pick that up as well but it will
only do that within a 10-minute window
so we don't keep around the event ID
deduplication table for a past 10
minutes so if you had a publisher maybe
going publishing a message at minute 1
and then they publish the same duplicate
message at you know hour 1 minute 1 you
would then have to account for that
elsewhere in your pipeline such as using
a unique transform so we're achieving
exactly once semantics within our
pipeline the next thing we may want to
do is think about how we deal with bad
data in order to deal with bad data
coming into our system we're actually
going to add some things to our
architecture such as pub sub to handle
as a dead-letter topic and claude
functions than to alert on messages
which ended up in that dead letter topic
so this so what does this look like in
actuality so we have this this message
being published in you can notice that
this message is malformed in some way we
don't have a closing tag on our JSON
object the event ID is is no longer in
the proper format so we were expecting a
string and now it's it doesn't have the
quotes around it so by default if this
was to enter our pipeline it's going to
fail when we try to parse these messages
right in data flow will actually try to
reprocess those messages forever in
streaming mode because we don't want to
lose that
data so if that data fails and it throws
an exception right we don't want to just
drop it on the floor so we'll continue
to reprocess it forever or until you
tell us what to do with it
such as updating your pipeline or
creating a new path within your pipeline
to deal with the bad data so what do we
do we can actually edit our pardhu
function so each one of those boxes is a
pardhu function essentially you could
think of a pardhu function as almost
like a map in MapReduce pardhu function
has a process element method which where
it performs the computation and so as
opposed to just performing our
computation and outputting records what
we'll do is we'll wrap it in a try-catch
block and then we'll output filled
records for any exception to our
dead-letter tag and that dead-letter tag
allows us to then retrieve those
messages later on in our pipeline and
then do something with them such as
output them to a persistent store so if
we to go back to our pipeline here in
this case we are now redirecting our
messages to a different location we're
taking that dead letter tag and we are
then routing it to both bigquery and
pub/sub routing to bigquery and pub/sub
because we want our support team to be
able to analyze those bad data to be
able to inspect it within bigquery and
then we also want to output it to
pub/sub for ease of reprocessing and
alerting within our cloud function and
so in this example this is an example of
a bigquery table that you may see for
dead letter processing where we're
storing maybe the event timestamp the
payload in bytes and maybe the try to
convert the payload to a string to you
know show more data about that payload
so someone has more context so are the
attributes and the error message in the
stack trace and this way you know
someone can go in there see what the
problem is and then hopefully rectify it
so we've added handling for bad data
within our pipeline but we also may
actually have another case which may
cause failures and that's a schema
changes so for a mobile game
mention that we have partners that are
publishing this data so our partners are
publishing this data and they may want
to update the schema at some point and
we need to react to that within our
pipeline so we may need to add
additional fields within our pipeline
dynamically now we could do this not
dynamically we could have coordination
like we could call up the partner and
say we're gonna coordinate a release on
this date and have a lot of operational
overhead but we actually want to
dynamically handle this because then
we're free from that operational
overhead of handing having to manage it
so looking back at our messages we may
have a the message on the Left which is
the yellow message which is coming in
you know just as we expected in the
schema that we expected we also may have
a message on the right with like the the
green message here that has an
additional field so the partner may have
added like a device IP or some
contextual information that's that's
useful for them and we want to capture
that but if they added an additional
field we may fail on our insert into
bigquery so we're gonna have to account
for that within our pipeline so there's
a couple things that bigquery and
dataflow our couple features of bigquery
and data flow that allow us to do this
fairly efficiently bigquery allows for
schema changes which are additive within
the same table so schema changes happen
online and require no downtime and the
bigquery sink within data flow allows
that you're the retrieval of failed
inserts combining all these things
together we can actually achieve this
dynamic mutating schema within our
pipeline if we were to look at our
pipeline again we may add in the get
filled inserts when we're writing out -
ready now to bigquery this allows us to
retrieve everything that has failed
insertion to bigquery then we may invoke
a function which dynamically mutates our
schema so everything that failed insert
inspect it add the additional field to
bigquery and then pass it downstream and
then finally writing those mutated
records out
now this allows us to do this fairly
efficiently so alternatively what we
could have done is we could have
inspected every single message which
enters our pipeline and that's fairly
inefficient because you're doing an
operation on a bunch of elements that
you may not need to write this schema
change may only happen occasionally and
so you're just adding overhead to your
pipeline so as opposed to doing that
reacting to the failed inserts and then
mutating the schema dynamically and
rewriting those records out to bigquery
allows us to have efficient dynamic
mutating schemas within data flow so if
we were to look at our pipeline again
how does this look
we have messages that may have mutated
schema and essentially we've added a
whole new path here in which errors come
out and then we validate and we mutate
that schema and then we re out put it to
bigquery and so without having to have
this complexity of managing changes with
our partners we're able to react to it
automatically within our pipeline
another common use case is real-time
denormalization so in order to provide a
summary view in our data warehouse we
may want to look up reference data
before we output events in our mobile
gaming use case this could be looking up
reference data like on the user or on
the partner adding contextual
information that will help us do our
analysis later in order to accomplish
this we'll need to add an additional
datastore to our architecture in this
case we'll choose BigTable because of
the scalability and latency requirements
that we may have our game is popular we
may be processing thousands hundreds of
thousands or million of events per
second so we need something that can
scale to that before we implement the
per record lookups we want to consider
both the performance of the database so
if we're doing this is within GCP we're
gonna prefer BigTable or data store to
do these per record lookups because
they'll give us the performance metrics
that we need if we were to reach out to
bigquery it'd be quite a bit slower
because you're talking
the orders of seconds as opposed to on
the orders of tens of milliseconds for
you that each individual lookup and we
also want something that's scalable too
because if we put let's say a single
Postgres instance to do our lookups data
flow is like a cannon we shoot at GCP
products and so you can easily make a
single instance fall over so we want to
keep that in mind when we're doing our
per record lookups and finally we also
want to utilize the right areas to
initialize and teardown our connections
pardhu's within data flow have a life
cycle and I'll speak to that life cycle
in just a second but essentially we want
to make sure that we're initializing in
Theriault on these connections in the
proper place within our pipeline so
within the app setup method of the do
function and within the app teardown
method of the do function to close the
connect connection so we to look at the
pardhu life cycle this is sort of a
crude representation of what it might
look like we have at setup start bundle
and process elements and then we also
have you finish bundle and teardown
so where do we do our connection
initialization and and teardown we're
gonna do that in setup and teardown just
like it sounds like and the reason being
is because it's executed once per doofen
instance so as these functions are
distributed across your worker pool
within your job it's executed once and
so you don't have a ton of setup and
teardown connections it is rather
expensive to create new connections and
tear them down all the time start bundle
and finish bundle are executed once per
bundle of Records so within the pipeline
data flow will actually bundle records
up and then process them to each
transform and this allows it to do to be
more efficient and not have to
materialize the output for each
individual record and we could have done
it here but this would be executed a lot
more frequently because there's going to
be a lot more bundles within the
pipeline than there are instances of the
do fund so this would be a decent place
to actually initialize and teardown our
connections but it would not provide the
performance that we would like and
finally we have the process element
method
this is executed once per worker if you
do really expensive things in the
process element method this is where you
can slow down your pipeline so for
instance initializing connections and
tearing them down if you're doing that
for each individual record and you're
processing sitting records at hundreds
of thousands or millions per second you
are going to slow down your pipeline
quite a bit and so that's why it's
pretty critical to connect and tear down
your connections to do these external
lookups in the correct place within your
do fund so zooming in on our pipeline
again we want to add rich data from an
external store and essentially we just
have added a couple different methods to
the enriched messages do fund
essentially now we're in the app setup
method we're initializing that
connection we're calling a method to
enrich the record which will then call
out to our external data store and then
we in our teardown method we're closing
down that connection and this allows us
to have efficient per record lookups
within our pipeline then if we look at
what our pipeline looks like as we add
in this functionality essentially we
have this additional lookup here
connecting to BigTable doing the per
record lookup and richen the data with
either user data or partner data for a
game events and then passing that data
downstream so now that we've done a lot
of the common functionality that we may
have to our pipeline we may want to
perform analysis on the data that's
moving through so this is where we may
want to utilize some of the window and
techniques that I had mentioned earlier
so here we don't need to add any
additional components to our
architecture because windowing is
handled within data flow itself so
there's nothing that's that needs to be
added here and for our analysis as I
alluded to earlier we want to do some
analysis to perform how long is the user
spent playing a game we may also want to
possibly know when the user stopped
playing we may want to do things like
for a session grouped together all the
events and then compute an output one
aggregate record that contains an array
using big queries nested and repeated
fields to our advantage
and so here we'll actually do the you
know how long is a user spent playing a
game now if we were to use fixed windows
we inherently have problems because we
may have family members that use the
same device and so if we were just to
group by fixed windows of a period of
time from like twelve to one or
something like that we may actually end
up with different individual users
within that time period and so that
would throw off our analysis of the
count of messages that we're seeing per
user or even any additional analysis
that we're doing on the user behavior so
this would have incorrect correlations
what we really want is utilize the
session name that I had mentioned
earlier because with session windows
what we achieve is what we really want
we basically group together the events
by a key and that key being a user ID
for instance and then we're able to get
all the events for a particular user
into one window and then compute
aggregations and do analysis on that
window before passing that data
downstream and so this gives us exactly
the subdivisions that we want so looking
at our pipeline code we window the
sessions with a gap of five minutes so
essentially we are going to look at
bursts of activity and whenever we do
not see activity for five minutes we
will close that window and we'll fire it
off and that will trigger the
aggregation downstream in our processing
after that we're going to key by the
user ID so essentially we're gonna take
that game event coming in and then we're
going to get the user ID and this would
actually creates a key value pair that
we can then group by so essentially
we're keen these records before we group
them so we can get their records into
the right place then we're going to
group by those records so we're going to
group by that key that we have with the
game events and that's basically going
to create a grouping of a key
to an array of all the records that map
to that key within that session and then
finally we're going to call a method or
class which is going to analyze our
events so within this this class we can
do the the counting or the averaging of
those records we can do the behavior
analysis that we want to and really we
can do any analysis that we see fit for
the our use case so now looking at our
updated pipeline we have this whole new
path after converting two rows we output
to session windows we key by the user we
group by the key and then we analyze the
events and it all happens before we pass
it downstream to bigquery so in this
example we did is we D duplicated
records using exactly once we handled
bad data we handled mutating data we
handled in rich in data in real time
with with these records and then we also
were able to then window these records
into meaningful windows for our use case
and compute analytics that that we
preferred them and so now I'm going to
hand it over to Oliver to talk us
through data flow at Skye
just to introduce myself I'm Oliver 280
I'm director of data engineering at Skye
and for those of people who who've not
heard a sky we're one of the leading TV
companies in Europe we've got 22 million
subscribers across the UK Italy Germany
and Austria and we're a quad play
provider so we do TV broadband phone and
mobile services and we selected Google
in 2017 primarily for its data
capabilities so we spent about four
months getting Google cloud set up for
Sky and designing our target
architecture and we've been open running
and live for eight months now so we
consider GCP to be a great data and
analytics platform as a service so today
I'm going to talk about Sky Q now Sky Q
is our flagship TV platform it's a TV
box and it we think it offers one of the
best TV experiences in
the UK in terms of quality of the
platform and the range of content
available for the box so sky queue as a
satellite tuner it is video on-demand it
does live streaming it does HD and UHD
content and what we do is we collect
diagnostic data from Sky Q boxes in
every customer's home and that's sort of
three million boxes at the moment as
live in the field so we want to collect
diagnostic data so we can understand
user journeys we want to be able to
optimize those G's attorneys so our
customers can find the TV content they
love easily so that means fewest clicks
or shortage shortest searches easy to
navigate UI promotions and
personalization so for example someone
clicks on the home menu they go to
movies they select a genre they find the
movie they press play so our original
solution for Sky Q analytics was based
on a Hadoop cluster it was a fixed sized
cluster on Prem and Sky Q great product
really successful but the problem was
that we had to deal with lots of peaks
of data so TV diagnostic data has large
Peaks so in the UK we don't have the
Webber of California unfortunately it
rains a lot when it rains people go
indoors they watch more TV they generate
more diagnostic events also we can have
news events we can have sports events
and on those days we get more diagnostic
events so the problem with our fixed
size system is that we have to over
provision so effectively from a yet if
we're provisioning to the yellow line we
have a lot of capacity that's wasted
whereas in worst case we under provision
the system and that means our batch
processing or real time jobs take longer
or worst case we lose data altogether
the other problem that we had was that
we spent a lot of time tuning our Hadoop
cluster I don't know how many people in
the audience run Hadoop but our ops team
spent time tuning yarn on a regular
basis and dealing with managing yarn
contain
we had a platform with mixed workloads
so it's very difficult to get those
workflows correct when things changed
over time so not a big surprise we move
to GCP and our architecture is designed
around pub/sub quiet dataflow and
bigquery the reason is that we chose
this is it's Google's canonical
architecture so really good integration
between all those components and we took
the opportunity to move the pipeline
from batch processing to streaming
because our modern key boxes report back
in real time over IP and the other thing
is that we chose to use dataflow to gain
the benefits of auto scaling serverless
architecture and out of order data
processing so much like Ryan's example
with mobile gaming people turn off our
TV boxes at night quite often we get
data turning up late so out of order
data processing is really important to
us so features in the beam model really
important and we also think that beam
model is becoming much more mature and
we like this sort of separation between
the runner and the SDK I think it's a
good thing to be able to abstract the
data pipeline itself from the
infrastructure or the runner so moving
on to talk about our architecture
effectively what we do here is we take
data in streaming mode in the India
stage so it's JSON data just like in the
mobile gaming example we take it from
our cue box into pub/sub separately we
take reference data batch mode into GCS
so then in our process stage what we do
is process this in data flow so in
streaming path we clean the data we are
additional attributes we assign join IDs
we session eyes the data so session
windows we turn a sequence of user
events into distinct TV sessions and
these are enriched with session IDs
at times and the event number of
sessions so we think that the ability to
dynamically add columns in bigquery when
our JSON schema changes is a great
feature and we make use of this so this
means we can have non breaking changes
with the source system so our source
system team just adds an element to the
JSON message and that manifests itself
in bigquery as a new column so what
we've got is also a separation between
our first stage of processing and
enrichment and the reason that we do
this is that we use our granular data
for multiple use cases and we don't
always want to be able to use the rich
enriched data in those separate use
cases so we have two stages of
processing in our architecture so in the
rich stage what we do is we create this
notion of cubox journeys and these box
journeys add things like the customer
details they add information around how
the planner works and different
reference data relating to the tiles on
the UI so for example we can see then
that somebody started searching for data
on the box they found Game of Thrones
and then they started watching Game of
Thrones and engaged in a big game of
Thrones TV marathon finally we display
all this in tableau so we've got a
number of aggregates that sit under
tableau and allow tableau to perform
effectively and give everyone really
kind of snappy performance so again like
in the example that Ryan was talking
about we make use of sessioning for our
TV events so sky processed sessions
based on a continuous stream of
diagnostic events each one of those is
calculated for an individual Sky key box
and we do this based on a four-hour gap
of inactivity so essentially what we're
looking for is that for our gap of of
inactivity and then everything in that
window before it becomes a session
we've got a hard cutoff after 24 hours
on the basis that we think no one
watches TV for more than 24 hours
so we also make use of auto scaling so
also scaling happens transparently but
interestingly the rules for auto scaling
are quite sophisticated so don't expect
auto scaling to happen immediately when
there's an influx of new work to do
sometimes it takes a while for data flow
to scale up and that's because it's got
a sophisticated heuristic in the
background working and optimizing the
number of workers in the data flow
pipelines so essentially it might add
workers to keep up with the input rate
so it knows the amount of unprocessed
work in pubsub or the queue depth and it
might also need to catch up with the
backlog and it's smart enough to
understand the rate of processing and
whether it's worth scaling up those
extra workers to process that backlog of
work so sometimes it might not scale up
because it'll realise that by the time
you scaled up and added more workers the
work would be done so what we've got now
is a situation where we can process many
hundreds of millions of records without
having to manage any of the
infrastructure and be able to cope with
those Peaks entirely dynamically so
we're regularly processing more than 300
million messages to a day in some cases
now well over 400 million it's been a
great success in the business it only
took five weeks to develop this solution
from end to end and we organised a bit
about whether we should pour our
existing apache spark code over and run
it on data proc and we think we right
made the right decision not to do that
and rewrite everything in data flow just
because we've taken all the benefit of
not having to manage the cluster we also
partnered with data tonic who may have
in the audience but data tonic are
experts in data engineering and machine
learning and
they were able to get our team up to
speed with Apache beam pub/sub bigquery
really quickly we do a/b testing on the
box software so we can determine whether
from one release of the key software to
the next that we're actually seeing
material benefits and improvements in
the software so typically what we do is
we take a small population of boxes we
roll those boxes up to the new revision
and we watch whether both old and new
cohorts of box users are performing as
we would expect and whether the new
cohort is seeing a material benefit and
in many cases we can now find that we're
seeing more than double-digit
improvements in performance of the UI
and user experience so quick summary of
before and after so before we had an
on-prem Hadoop cluster we have to manage
network servers software upgrades we had
to patch everything we had a lot to
maintain now we've got a completely
server list as a service model we can
scale in no time at all like 90 seconds
to add more work as whereas before we
were talking months to add new servers
where we may have to even put in a
request to Finance and deal with all of
the capital expenditure outlay so it's
high fixed costs with the existing
solution and now we can just pay for
what we use one of the biggest
improvements has been in development
time before with the fixed size system
on-premise it was almost impossible to
recreate that production workload
especially with multiple workloads
running on the same system so
development time took a long time
because it was very difficult to test
things and replicate the production
workload now we can replay all our
messages back into pub/sub through into
data flow and into the new developed
version of our pipeline and it's very
much very much simpler to test and
that's meant that development now
happening in weeks not months
and ops are delighted rather than
spending two days a week
cheating yarn it's near zero ops so gain
great success for sky and also a great
success for the business so Dan Connell
who heads up our products product
experience now fig feels that this is an
extension of the product design and
development capability so he says this
capability has the power to change the
way we develop our products and has made
me very proud of what we've built
together and finally I just like to say
a couple of thankies say data tonic who
partnered with us to build this and also
agile solutions who helped do some of
the project management so thanks to
Louie and Andrew on the technical side
at Data tonic and Steven from our gel
solutions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]